welcome to Muslims
I mean Alberto BOSU the director of the
National de Mining Institute Maputo
Mozambique where Mozambique was
colonized by Portugal so we had it to
fight the becoming independent later on
Mozambique had this civil war which
started in 1976 so during the fight we
use every kind of ammunition mines were
laid and schools villages military
barracks bridge abutments and other
infrastructures the development of
contrast at war was really slow after
the war in 1992 we started the remaining
probability the work was very tough was
very slow very painful working very hard
environment and then I was interested in
actually learning a new technology which
is mine detection rights
I grew up in rural areas I grew up in
poor areas I know the right is something
that every one hunting activity because
we have this thinking that the rat is
useless it's only creating problems but
now here in Mozambique the rat can do
something useful to save people's life
my name is Alberto Zacharias I'm the
mine detection rats supervisor
since our odds approach from the
beginning to detect the smell of
explosive so when they find an explosive
they give us a clues and such areas are
turning around sniffing around then
stretch
and the good thing about using the rats
is that the rights are more quick
precise and also cost-effective the rats
are really amazing creatures instead of
staying three four days to clear like
hundred square meters I could do it in
20 minutes and that makes huge
difference
every morning when I come to work I look
at their faces I see when they're
serious I see when they want to play and
I see how amazing they are when they
managed to get explosive
you put them in the cage back to the
heart you see them relaxing and that's
amazing in because it's like we do we
get our boots off and edenal I
understand the rights have became mine
best friend
so Mozambique was total destroyed but
when we started to do our mining
activities we saw people coming back to
their homelands trying to rebuild their
life
- meaning free from fear
they fear was if my daughter my son will
come back at the end of the day so that
fear is out from the community
and I feel very proud to drive around to
see some villages building new hospitals
new roads are being constructed
industries are being rebuilt and we use
drugs to clean those areas
I'm going to brigade up or become a
salvage value we are starting the moving
to development if you look Maputo today
is totally different in my body from ten
years ago people they can use more land
in the land is available now